now you can see it says there a function
capital f of X is defined as and then
they give you two things
right they give you two different
functions you might want to get a red
pin out and we call these sub functions
they're they're parts of a function that
make up another one so it's a bit like
what we did with the circles and
breaking up into pieces okay now I'm
gonna write this a little bit
differently than what's on the page
because this is how you'll actually get
it you've got one function and defined
into or really as many as you like
pieces
hence piecewise okay so here we've got
it's equal to this for a particular set
of values namely those okay and put all
the values it's equal to a different
function entirely okay now the question
doesn't ask it but we're gonna do it
what does this thing look like because
it's quite a simple example it's not
that hard to make sure so draw your set
of axes and generally we go from left to
right that tends to be the easiest way
to erase the inlet so the leftmost part
is this one axis less than zero
okay so nice idea is to start from your
boundary okay in this case zero right
now and you'll know what y equals x
looks like okay so I'm just gonna line
and I'm gonna label that pot know the
rest of the function is defined for this
okay you'll notice as well I didn't put
anything on the origin there because I
wasn't sure this thing doesn't tell you
what what's happening at the origin
right it means to the left of the origin
everything else and this is where the
origins define so it's 2x so say wine
but steep
okay so that's what the graph looks like
pretty simple it's a nice gentle start I
hope by the way this is for this whole
labeling of different you might have
called them branches before I'm you
Delhi this is the end of last year right
when you were doing where did you yeah
absolute value you got here some
function this look like this and then I
bent often did weird things okay
so absolute value my dears is really a
it's really a piecewise function we just
didn't give you the name okay so that's
what's that's really equal to how would
you describe it actually the definition
it's equal to X on what condition it's
the similar this isn't it for X is
greater than or equal to 0 okay what's
it equal to for the rest of the domain
yeah thank you it's flipped upside down
now I've so you might be curious how
come I've got the Equality here and like
here and the reason is well no reason in
this case I could flip it and it'd be
exactly the same no change okay but I'm
going to show you some example in a
second where it does make a difference
now question oh why why are we learning
about piecewise functions is it just cuz
up mathematicians want to make life hard
for you and they want to make one graph
twice as hard to draw
as you can there's mother uh let me
suggest piecewise functions your life is
full of piecewise functions you just
don't really think about it okay
example during the holidays I assume you
went to shops right and probably what
does they don't have their license you
like the peas or anything like that
you're all your own nerds you present
when you drive okay when you get to
drive you have to worry about pocket
park I made you worry about parking work
when you pay for parking how does that
work
well when you drive up to Paris you're
right there's a sign right there tell me
what you're about to be forced to pay
they say the first three hours are great
right so zero one two really if I say
time how long you've been in the car
park write all of that it costs you
nothing
yeah but then if the second you go over
I actually don't know what the numbers
are but it's nothing line attitude or
toodles for you or something like that
so as soon as you hit three hours you're
something else
right oh yeah okay and then when you
jump up to the next thing and then when
you you know you jump up to the next
thing because they're extortionists that
kind of thing what's this that's a
piecewise function okay let me give you
one more example before I leave off this
who's got a job come try what are you
did you say you probably catch it hands
so this point doesn't apply to you but
do you oh yeah okay
so whenever you get
yeah let's edit that out okay it's a
stomach honey he's like I don't care
whatever I'm just gonna leave that in
that'll be great okay
oh my remember that's where okay now uh
when you learn money money assuming
someone who doesn't just very shady put
you know cash in your hand if you have
to get a salary or something like that
okay the government takes money for off
you right and we call that tax surtax is
something your payback right versus your
earnings now maybe because your citrus
consumer is particularly annoying you
know basically how this works right
there's a simpler kind of system it's
not three hours it's like your first I
got change recently used to be five
grand I think it's now it's increased a
lot
yeah it's a some number of thousands of
dollars right so this is how much you
earn okay and you pay no tax but as you
start to earn more you start paying tax
your first dollar over eighteen thousand
dollars you pay some number of cents
right um so it's not quite like this
it's not like I'm an hundred thousand
one dollar so I take this big cut out of
me that doesn't change that will
increase for every dollar you there
right but that's not all doesn't doesn't
do that forever you meet what's called a
tax bracket right so you're I can't know
what the numbers actually are but yeah
okay so my scale is terrible for that so
I'm gonna call that like 21
so what they do is you seen the table
right they take more cents out of the
dollar okay so what effect does that
have on this you know it climbs more
rapidly okay and then it climbs really
rapidly right doesn't quite do that but
you get me
what happened in my cell phone a cancer
that's animation bad idea you get the
idea okay so again piecewise function
okay piecewise functions exist
everywhere in life where things don't
fit new rules for everything okay we
want different rules for different
things or difficult or different people
or anything like that so that's these
messages I'm allowed to give you a whole
bunch of examples they're not on the
sheet because I couldn't find a good
exercise before and what about you to do
is dry yourself a new set of artists for
each one and then graph them as now I'm
going to give you more than two sub
functions function because that's what
and I'm also going to give you a few
where they do if they have nicely and
don't like me at one point they're going
to do this okay so if you've got another
color their label this a graph like this
as opposed to those two right it's full
of discontinuities it is not sorry
discontinued it it is not continuous in
that category we've got really important
they don't look into calculus in limits
okay sir
watch out for that quick question you
can see my film and hollow circles how
will you know three hours braces how do
you know this one should be filled and
that one should be hollow or the other
way around I can tell that's yeah that's
right so look carefully is what we
talked about before
look carefully where there's an equality
there right where there's an equality
that's where I'm going to full circle
okay so I put the circle up here because
I know they say under three hours free
the second you hit three hours if you
were driving out and it equal three
hours they'll charge you okay so that's
why it's a full circle all right